Hi, I'm Philip and I'm the CEO at
Wordware. Today I want to talk to you
about what sucks about chatbased
interfaces, how documents can actually
solve those issues and how do they lead
to um background agents that do tasks
for you in the or in the background. So
firstly, let's start with what are the
problems with chatbased systems. When I
interact with um cla or open AI, it all
seems very affirmal. um I end up often
creating workflows for myself using
projects or just copy pasting stuff and
in that way when I'm kind of having
these long conversations that I populate
the context window I realized that a lot
of these uh things in the context window
are just
like gibberish and garbage and so we get
context pollution. I also don't get to
iterate in a structured manner. If I'm
working with artifacts, it ends up that
I basically make the context window
dirty enough with not being able to, you
know, change one sentence that I really
want wanted to make sure that it's
precise. I also sometimes lack another
level of forced clarity. Chad GPT often
asks me that one particular question
around, oh, in deep research, what would
you like to actually find? that it never
actually asks me in the right way when
it's not actually certain about some
things and therefore not forcing me to
clarity. Also, there's a couple more
issues about poor version control,
limited reusability, model laziness. The
more the context grows, the less uh you
know, the worse response I'm getting.
Also, chat interfaces don't support any
logical grouping or nesting um in any
way. And we also are interacting with a
single abstraction layer. We don't get
to see and choose whether we want to
specify every small detail of a
particular task or just set it up in
some way. Hence, documents. Documents
are actually the original way of
specifying more complex systems. the
first um product requirements dock that
dates uh probably to Noah's arc around
three and a half thousand years ago. Uh
don't check me on that one, however. Uh
and um it's the first kind of take um on
someone explaining a more complex system
uh to somebody who is not aware of how
to build it. Um and therefore um
documents are actually the ultimate way
of humans communicating these more
complex ideas and so in that way we get
force clarity uh which is great but next
problem with chat and one of the biggest
problems with chat is um concurrency um
we have concurrency of one with all
chatbased systems we need to be sitting
there and we are getting like the um
inklinks of how the future will look
like when um manus or deep research uh
are running in the background and
actually you know doing things for us.
It feels great. It feels great that
there's something in the background
that's
happening. So now you know let's riff
off this idea of the background um
agents that I'm going to introduce.
So we've been doing work and computers
have been doing work for us uh in the
background for quite a while and you
know we've kind of created workflows
which are kind of handcrafted. You can
think of the zapier of this world and
then we're just barely starting to
create specialized um agents. That
basically means that at some stage it
kind of had an if else statement that
was somewhat fuzzy and it made one or
two decisions.
And as we can see on this diagram, when
their importance of some workflow is
high and the occurrence is high, we
actually end up using handcrafted
workflows. We're only now entering an
area where the general agents um are
starting to take some decisions. But
whenever we have kind of higher
importance, we don't let that general
agent to um kind of enter our life.
So how can we remedy this? Um we
remedied this by introducing a human in
the loop. Um so essentially now uh with
the human in the loop the agent can do a
bunch of work and we get to approve,
reject it, change the way that it's
created the end output or even fix its
logic
entirely. Um they normally react to some
kind of implicit or explicit user intent
or trigger. So you can think of of these
background agents as being activated by
a sent email, send slack message, maybe
your meeting, that could be an implicit
trigger that you had a meeting with a
name um party and that party with
investors and that could prompt you to
update your
CRM. And with having a bunch of these
ambient agents, you end up having to
create protocols of how humans and the
AIS communicate between themselves. And
that basically means that you know both
humans can control the agents and its
outputs but also different agents can
communicate with each other to educate
themselves around you know sources of
data. an agent. One agent could be
communicating with a more general agent
around what is in your notion. And in
that way, we'll probably start with a
consumer first where a bunch of agents
are working in the background. But very
soon that starts to be about an
organization. And we'll start having
organizations which have their own
agents and also external agents. And in
that way we might even get agents which
manage other humans which sounds
ridiculous at the beginning but actually
you know that could be just an agent
which creates Jira tickets for all of
your engineers and in that way we
basically create the graph of the
enterprise of the future. I think when I
think about these background agents
firstly kind of working for the consumer
maybe managing your emails and just
making sure that you have more time for
yourself. I think this idea like so
naturally represents a bottom-up
movement to enterprises which will be
more slowm moving and trying to make
sure that all of their agentic tools
that these agent need to be using are
verified and have the right authority
and they have the right permissions and
they don't mess things up. So as I am
thinking about the future of the agent
economy, I think that the stoastic
mindset like we need to adopt that
because we essentially need to bleed
with leverage over uncert uncertainty.
If something that you don't fully get
how it works, closes you clients and
delivers on business value. Um 99.9% of
the time we're not going to care about
the fact that we don't understand what's
happening in that 0.1% of the time.
we're just going to make sure that the
impact of the 0.1% of the time is not
catastrophic. Um I also think humans
will manage a bunch of agents and that's
why taste and intent is so important. Um
you will need to imbue your own personal
brand onto agents and take
responsibility for their actions. We'll
also need a lot more communication
protocols between humans and AI and also
in between agents. The MCP is the first
protocol that kind of sets it up but I
think it lacks more information about
what are the constraints of a particular
agents, what are the authority that it
needs to uh have in order to act,
whether it needs approval from human in
the loop etc.
Um like right now when I think about
like kind of humans managing agents, we
only see this properly in coding. And in
coding, we basically see people who are
good engineers who are good both at IC
work and at managing a team of interns
really, really, really being able to
take the benefit of the AI revolution.
Um, a lot of excellent IC engineers end
up saying, "Oh, I I don't want to use
AI. It's um, it's actually not that good
as people are saying and it probably
isn't for them, but their bar for uh,
code might be too high. They want might
want to have everything optimized in the
right manner." And in this way, you
know, this is the first time where um
engineers are kind of managing the swarm
of agents and they need to be good at
managing in order to actually distill
um leverage and distill benefit for
their organization.
Um so just to just to wrap up um I think
the concurrence of one of chatbased
systems and the pollution you get
through playing with them it almost is
like brainstorming but after
brainstorming you need to sit down and
create a right document to explain what
an agent should be doing. This is only
needed for repeatable processes. Once
you have a repeatable process that you
trust and you think will be very useful,
you can hook hook it up to a trigger
that can be either you know a chron job
or it could be uh a Gmail trigger or it
could be an implicit trigger. Then that
agent is then able to act in the
background. The latency matters a little
bit less there and only surface issues
to you once it is struggling with
something or needs your approval.
Therefore, your work is mostly around
creating these assignments for the um
for the agents, making sure that your
taste is imbued there and then approving
the results of the work, making sure you
trust it more and more and more as you
keep going. In that way, we are creating
swarms of agents which are working in
the background and our main job is to
swipe left and right as if it's Tinder
and approve and edit the results of the
work of the agents.
I think from there the consumer um
market is going to adopt this much more
widely and we're going to see um it
slowly entering the enterprise market
and I'm super excited about the
enterprises creating most incredible
tools uh that are going to be agentic
and they are going to be used by the
state-of-the-art newest models but the
tools are going to be the mode. So a
very clear progression uh for the
future. Let's see if it's true. Thank
you so much. I'm Philip, the co-founder
and CEO of Wardware. And at Wardware, we
actually enable these background agents
to work.